The climate is changing.
Low carbon development
is an approach
to reducing carbon
dioxide emission
and mitigating global warming.
Human activities
in cities produced
78% of global carbon emission.
This is because most
cities rely heavily
on fossil fuel-based energy.
Low carbon development
refers to ways
of shaping economic growth
so that greenhouse gas
emissions can be kept to levels
that can be absorbed by nature.
Low carbon development
involves a push
towards simpler lifestyles
that rely on environmentally
friendly technologies.
Hello, my name is Isiaka
Adeyemi Abdul-Azeez,
and I'm a research scholar
with the MIT-UTM Malaysia
Sustainable Cities Program.
In this video, I will discuss
why and how low carbon
development is proceeding
in the second largest city
in Malaysia, Johor Bahru.
The city is in the
Iskandar Malaysia region,
which has announced a goal of
reducing carbon emission by 58%
by year 2025.
I will reflect on some of
the city's achievements
and the challenges it faces
in meeting that target.
Johor Bahru is one of the
five local authorities
in Iskandar Malaysia region.
It is an important flagship
for low carbon development
in the region.
The city is a regional
transport manufacturing hub
and a main shopping
destination for tourists
from Indonesia and Singapore.
At present, it very
disorganized and much
messier than its glitzy
neighbor Singapore.
In an effort to
compete with Singapore,
the Malaysian government
announced a commitment
to sustainable
urban development.
Its goal was to attract
foreign investment
in Johor Bahru's industrial,
commercial, and real estate
activities.
Economic investment
usually means
more construction of
buildings, more manufacturing
and industrial development, more
retail and shopping activities,
more concentration
of human activities,
and more energy consumption
for transport and electricity.
Under normal
circumstances, all these
would increased carbon emission.
However, the
government is trying
to promote economic growth while
reducing the carbon intensity.
How can this be done?
And how is low
carbon development
being practiced in Johor Bahru?
Two key organizations are
leading the low carbon
initiative in Johor Bahru.
The first is the Office
of Low Carbon Society,
at the University of Technology
in Malaysia, also called UTM.
Professor Ho Chin Siong, the
head of the Low Carbon Society
office at UTM explains
some of their practices
he has been trying to
encourage in Johor Bahru.
We use the concept
of [INAUDIBLE], where
they have already some form of
[INAUDIBLE], or [INAUDIBLE],
and then other thing is
the climate change policy.
How can be integrate them
together in such a way
that urban planning
can decarbonize?
That plan basically guided
us how to be low carbon.
And then, from
there, we prepared
another plan called
the Road Map, that
is the [? implementation ?]
of the plan.
And then at the moment, we are
now going into more detail,
working with the local
authorities, with the mayors,
with the engineers.
The second
organization concerned
with promoting low carbon
development initiatives
in Johor Bahru is the Iskandar
Regional Development Authority,
also known as IRDA.
Together with UTM, IRDA, is
helping local authorities
prepare actions plans for
reducing carbon intensity.
Mr. Boyd Joeman
explains what IRDA
is doing along these lines.
The process of getting to
that point is very important.
So municipal, critical.
And that's why we are working
with the five local authorities
to prepare their own
low carbon action
plan at the municipal level.
Through that
process, we can then
say we have done one step
further from regional
to municipal.
They can then look
at it from the point
of view of how they developed
their respective areas.
So we bring them
to Japan and let
them see a bigger picture-- how
it is being done in a developed
country.
And then they bring back, and
then the disseminate and share
the information.
So through that process,
IRDA can play a big role
in terms of making sure
that everyone is connected,
as it were.
Regarding what has been achieved
thus far in Johor Bahru,
Professor Ho has this to say.
The first thing, I
think, awareness.
Awareness of the [INAUDIBLE].
Low carbon strategy
is not a new term
anymore in this Iskandar
area or in [INAUDIBLE] area.
People are talking about
low carbon society.
And people believe that,
actually, low carbon society
will improve the
quality of life.
Another achievement
is the creation
of environmentally
friendly rural communities.
One of these
villages, [INAUDIBLE],
has been supported by
the government as a model
for low carbon lifestyle.
The village has
implemented a series
of action plans in
various sectors,
such as agricultural
and waste disposal, that
demonstrates how a community
can live more sustainably.
[INAUDIBLE] project was
adopted by the residents
of [INAUDIBLE] and shows how
the population can benefit
socially, environmentally,
and economically
through various low carbon
development efforts.
Among the key obstacles
to promoting low carbon
development is
changing the mindset
of those who have
not embraced the need
to reduce carbon intensity.
Professor Ho offers some
suggestions regarding ways
of changing local thinking.
The [INAUDIBLE]
approach is actually
focusing on co-benefits.
I think it's too early stage
for the [INAUDIBLE] country,
when they tell them, OK,
let's go for low carbon.
Let's save the planet.
Let's cut down CO2, it may not
make sense to many of them.
But if you tell them that there
is a co-benefit-- for instance,
by going low carbon,
you can save money.
By having low carbon
you have a co-benefit
of better air quality, better
health, better quality of life.
By having even going
green, or low carbon,
you can do composting,
or you can do recycling,
and then by doing
that activities,
you can generate certain
extra income for the family.
Those are co-benefit,
I believe strongly,
that help us to promote it.
Measuring and monitoring carbon
emissions from electricity
and the transport sector
is carried out for IRDA
by UTM and Japanese researchers,
as Mr. Boyd Joeman explains.
Through the Low Carbon
Society blueprint,
which was prepared by UTM in
Japan, [INAUDIBLE] University
and [INAUDIBLE]
University and the NIS.
Through that, they did
the homework, i.e.,
what are the existing emissions
or the output of electricity,
for example, or transport.
So from then on, we have
a base figure, 2005.
At this point, it's
being monitored
through the project, i.e.
by UTM in Japan.
But eventually, IRDA needs
to sit down and monitor
it ourselves.
One cannot manage what
one cannot measure,
and monitoring is only possible
once there is agreement on what
to measure.
Emissions from transport
and electricity production
must be measured and monitored.
MOSFET is an emissions
measuring tool
that is being used to assess
carbon dioxide emission
from transport and electricity.
The tool measures fossil
fuel-based energy use
by category, type, and sector.
It inventories electricity use
in kilowatt hours and liters
of fuels.
These are automatically
converted into carbon dioxide
equivalents.
The emission
reduction goal can be
achieved using MOSFET
to monitor the carbon
reduction from transport and
electricity in Johor Bahru.
The Malaysian economy is
growing at almost 2% per year,
so reducing carbon
intensity will not be easy.
The way forward is
to create support
for the world we
want to live in.
Reducing carbon intensity
and promoting low carbon
development in Johor
Bahru and elsewhere
would require a change in
the mindset of many people.
It will also be necessary
to agree on what to measure
and how to monitor
changes in carbon
intensity in each sector.
More low carbon
model villages should
be created to show how low
carbon development can meet
the needs of the population.
Other experiments and
prototype living arrangements
will be necessary to convince
people that change is possible.
Shifting to clean energy will
undoubtedly be important.
Along these lines, Johor
Bahru will probably
need to implement
financial incentives
to encourage investment
in renewable energy,
along with multiple changes
in consumer behavior.
City planners will
need to explain
what less energy intensive
patterns of development
might look like.